I How do you describe this look of like the face? Is it that
it looks like she has a facelift, but she did? It's like God
gave her a botched facelift naturally through genetics.
How like why is this Why is this eye pulling up so significantly?
What in the is happening? Here's the real here's here's the real
question. Why would you wear skirts when you got knees like this?
What is this? There's like eight different kneecaps going on
in this one knee. Absolute zero out of 10 knees. Gross. Get that
[__] off my timeline.
Transition segue. We can go from one person exploring interracial
dating to another person exploring interracial dating. Why don't
we do this as a prelude to the stream? Okay, we've got a 25minute
video from Britney Venty on Pearl Davis. The tragic end of Pearl
Davis and the red pill. The tragic end. Speaking of women who
hate their parents. Okay. Wait, a new black guy. Pearl only dates
black guys. Pearl hates her parents a lot. Okay. They've got
a lot of money. She hates them a lot. Some people say that. I
I'm hesitant to believe that. Okay. >> I was born kind
of chopped. I always knew from a young age I was kind of mid.
Not necessarily beautiful. I've always been a certified mid.
You know, I would look at women more attractive than me that
would get
>> God. Pearl's existence is just tragic in >> More
opportunities. I've always been a certified mid. >> Nothing
screams self-worth like having to explain to your audience how
mid you are. But apparently she also thinks that she looks better
than Sydney Sweeney because her s said so. This is Pikmi Pearl
looks better than Sydney. >> Um I'm sorry. Sydney Sweeney
does look like really mousy without makeup on, but let's be honest.
People see Sydney Sweeney somewhere, they're not even looking
at her face, okay? That's not the That's not why Sydney Sweeny's
like the woman on earth or whatever. Okay,
I'll just be real. That's not what people are looking at. I'm
just spoiler >> Sweeny because her s said so. This is >> Oh,
also she's not even unattractive. I'm just saying she's like
a little mousy. She's like, you guys, >> she's called that
because so many guys want to pick her over Sydney Sweeney, of
course, which is why she dated a homeless guy. Let's pick up
where we left off. Pearl took it upon herself to run her >> a
homeless black man.
A homeless black man. Crazy. >> Her catfish awards on She
took an 8-year-old edited photo of me after she >> Okay,
I listen. I'm all about, you know, makeup being something where
you go from like uh, you know, a five to an eight or something,
a six to a nine. I'm I'm all for believing that makeup can make
you way more attractive, but that's unbelievable, right? That's
really unbelievable. There's no way it's real. I don't think
I don't think it could possibly be real. I don't think so. That's
a lot, man. >> So, I said that I >> So, why is one
of them just a picture of her chest? >> Retiring from YouTube
and used it to say that I'm a cat.
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. [laughter] >> I
said that I was retiring from YouTube
>> and used it. Dude, this is like the Wait, it's just
like edited for color though, isn't it? Like the shape of the
face is not really changed.
Am I crazy?
Oh, no. Nose changes a little bit. It's not a lot of change.
It's just the coloring, but the coloring is really >> I'm
a catfish. Brave choice, Pearl. Especially when you have me blocked
from applying. I'm sorry that we can't all be natural beauties
like you. She chalks it up to makeup here. And yeah, Pearl, it
does take work to develop the skill to learn how to do your makeup
properly, you know, so that you don't look like you're using
your grandmother's 20-year-old drugstore eyeliner. Here's a >> That's
a rough one. Okay,
that's Listen,
we all understand. Nobody Nobody who's over the age of like 25
really wants a high death photo of themselves, okay?
Nobody wants that. No, not a single person on Earth. I don't
even know why they put 4K cameras on the selfie thing. Okay,
I actually don't know. Nobody wants that. Nobody wants to see
in high definition how old they are. They look like the [__]
Keeper. Here's a tip for Pearl. Lightweight concealer is really
good for not settling into premature wrinkles around the eye.
Pearl does a really good job at not looking her age. I can't
believe she's 28 years old. >> What up, guys? Welcome to
another episode of Pearl. >> Dude. Okay. She That's a That's
a rough 28. Wait, how old is Britney Venty? Wait, what? Britney
Venty age? She got to be older than that. No. Oh, the same age.
That's That's rough. Okay,
that's that's rough that her and Britney Benty are the same age.
Pearl. Pearl strikes me as like
she is the
uh would she be like the prototypical example of why I don't
know how to say this. I feel like most most women most guys almost
certainly think that Pearl is trans when they see her in real
life, right? Like they have to.
Pearl is like huge. She got a big jaw. Not not very much makeup.
I just feel it looks that way. daily. Today we have a special
guest.
>> Listening to this clip when she opens her mouth is like
a flashbang.
>> Up guys. >> Not everyone knows Pearl's lore. So,
I'm going to go ahead and give a quick rundown. Hannah Pearl
Davis is a rich kid that runs her YouTube channel on her daddy's
dime, which is how she was able to keep it running after being
demonetized. She was demonetized right after she interviewed
miners about the morality of stealing a famous rapper's >> Think
about it, right? Do you really think he didn't think to wrap
it up with the I'm going to say cornstar? He's a player, right?
He knows. He knows she's a cornstar. He probably did. She probably
stole it, >> which their family weren't too happy about,
but she kept the video up. Pearl is also known for talking about
how 16. Dude, this is the rough thing about if you're somebody
who really likes Nick Fentes, okay? Cuz I know that's what this
is is her following along with Nick. Nick has pied pipered many
of people off a career cliff. Okay, you cannot you cannot repeat
the things Nick Fentes says if you're not Nick Fentes. Okay,
that's like a there's like a one-time exception for somebody
who's funny enough in a generation to be like that. And Pearl
is not that guy. Pearl's not that woman. Pearl cannot do that.
Okay.
Also, I don't think Flintes would tweet this out quite precisely.
Okay. He says it he says it in a certain way that makes it kind
of okay. Not really, but kind of.
Pearl could never Pearl should never have attempted it. Okay.
She literally lost her entire career. That's got to be right.
Pearl lost her entire career trying to copy what Fuentes did
and then he just like rockets off. Totally like total
rocket trajectory into the stratosphere and she just like killed
her career doing the same thing. That's [__] up.
>> 18-year-olds are hotter than 25year-olds
showcasing her feminine maternal instinct to protect children.
And this idea that women are somehow nurturing and motherly is
just the biggest lie that we have ever told in our society. >> As
feminine as she is nurturing, she's known for preaching to her
audience how men want women that are feminine, docile, pure,
and beautiful. She leads by example, making so much effort in
her minimal skincare routine, as well as her hair styling. >> Dude,
dude, why this? It's just jump scare pictures of Pearl the whole
time. The entire thing is just jump scare pictures of Pearl.
What the [__] are we doing? Is that really a video?
That's like the most It's like you're a woman, so you can just
do you can just have the most misogynistic video the whole time,
I guess. >> And her girly gorilla posture. She's doing
a fantastic job showing off the >> Oh, hold on. I got to
back it up. >> She's known for preaching to her audience
how men want women that are feminine. docile, pure, and beautiful.
She leads by example, making so much effort in her minimal skincare
routine, as well as her hair styling and her girly gorilla posture.
She's doing a fantastic job showing off those succulent pitties
lately. So, if I were
>> Dude, I [__] haven't plugged the soundboard
in. Dude, what
>> her I would wear longer sleeves and invest in a micro
bra. But I guess Pearl is still experimenting with her fashion
at almost 29 years old to find the right piece of clothing that
will flatter her Sasquatch stance. Pearl loves to pass time making
comments on women and their appearances because they're all being
hoes, especially if they're wearing a minikrt. You don't understand.
It's different when Pearl does it because then it's under the
guise of I lost weight. And it's the same case for makeup, too.
She's basically calling women prostitutes for wearing makeup,
but it's fine when she does science experiments with hers. Some
things, Dude. Dude, it's a science experiment.
That's That's haunting, bro. The like I How do you describe this
look of like the face? Is it that it looks like she has a facelift,
but she did? It's like God gave her a botched facelift naturally
through genetics.
How?
Like why is this why is his eye pulling up so
>> What the is happening? >> Some things just never
change. But one of those things that actually has is that Pearl
is no longer single. She now has a new man's beliefs to pair
it. Her boyfriend, Nuclear Cowo. Look at them go. She's got the
grace of a cardboard box. Her boyfriend is another one of these
red pill manosphere guys that's here to teach his audience how
to get laid. We're not here to win or sorry, we're not here to
to prove that we're better than anyone or that anyone's uh daddy
internet daddy is better than someone else's. We're here to win.
We're here to get laid. >> He's not a loser. He has strategy
like using an app. >> Bro, isn't that like the end of the
internet career as a dating expert? Like lifestyle expert is
you landed Pearl. That's like your big W.
Isn't that like it's over then? Is this like done? We're done.
You're done.
Like that's bro, what are you trying to make everybody whoever
gave you money kill themselves?
The you doing >> that fakes live stream viewership to get
women to twerk for him at parties.
>> His channel is about teaching men how to extract from
women with the lowest investment possible, which is how he got
Pearl. Unfortunately for him, his alpha red pill selfies just
weren't enough. >> It's like over for the Twitch stream.
It never takes off again. Unfortunately for him, his alpha red
pill selfies just weren't enough for him to be Pearl's first
choice. Because Pearl says that the female fantasy is to get
someone out of their league. And that's why Pearl is always thirsting
after other guys. Whether it's the whatever podcast host that
she's worked with. >> Wow, he was really cute back in the
day. >> Just got fat. >> Or her bowing down to this
black guy that isn't her [laughter] boyfriend calling him king.
>> I'm not here to lower your compass. >> Is there
content for feminists?
I don't know who Brett I Venty just makes her own stuff. Benty
just wants to be mean.
That's all she wants. She just wants to be mean to everybody.
Okay.
>> Really cute back in the day.
>> Dude. Dude, I would never have thought Brian was like
that fat
until I saw these pictures. Like he is he is like actually super
skinny and looks totally
Like that picture is so different. What the It's like a totally
different dude. I would never have thought he was like fat. I
thought I was like, "Oh, that's like a normal looking guy."
And then like I knew he gained a little weight, but he he was
actually like super in >> He just got fat. >> Or
her bowing down to this black guy that isn't her boyfriend, calling
him >> I'm not here to lower your compass.
>> I'm just really letting you know, be honest, these are
good. These are good. These are good. >> And Pearl just
cannot contain herself around her colleague Andrew Wilson. >> Maybe
Young Andrew.
[clears throat] So ladies, >> wait that it's so funny.
Like you think you think when that picture that >> Wait,
wait, wait. That's Andrew in high school or something. >> Andrew
like [snorts] the >> What the Okay, I don't want to I don't
want to be gay, but like he looks like a model. What the [__]
What the [__] He looks What the hell? Average Joe,
bro. Look at those cheekbones. You can like see the highlight
the shadows of the cheekbones. What the
>> he does have kids for a reason? I didn't think his kids
were his.
Did Did he have his own kids with his I And that's not a shot
at him, by the way. But I thought I didn't think his kids were
his. >> Enough for that guy to ever look. >> Yeah,
he wouldn't. >> She's thirsting after a guy who would be
unable to open a pickle jar for her. And this is the same guy
who rated his wife, Rachel Wilson, a 6 out of 10. >> Most
women are going to exist between the 5 to six average, slightly
above average. Where does my wife fall? Well, she falls right
in at that average to slightly above average. Absolutely brutal.
I
[laughter]
it's How is this It feels like it's not a hard line to walk.
Like
my wife is beautiful. I love my wife. My wife is beautiful. I
love my wife. My wife is beautiful. She's the most beautiful
woman to me in the world. I love my wife. How hard is that?
Somebody asks you, "Okay, rate her on a scale 1 to 10." No. That's
like that woman is the most important woman in my life. I'm I'm
never rating her on a scale of 1 to 10. That's up. I I get that
people like think that's a thing to press on. It's like, dude,
that's somebody I care about. What the
Just say 10. Okay, you could just say
>> I bet one of her three baby daddies would have given
her a higher rating. >> So, Andrew, can I um sell you on
my
>> Your wife has three baby daddies and has been married
twice before. >> Uh-huh. You lick sn
with the three baby. >> What did I just say? >> Wife
with the three. >> Sorry, doll. I'm sorry. Is she morally
inconsequential in comparison to your ditch licking? >> I
guess we know why he made her take a paternity test. >> I
have what I would consider 100% faith and trust in my wife. I
told her these words exactly. You're going to get the test and
if not, I'm out the door.
>> It's not 100% faith. Wait. No. Wait.
Andrew, you're Christian. You should know what faith is. What
the Why is this like plus-sized women plus Farah?
What? We need a bunch of very large women
and one fake virgin. Okay, we need these things together. Dude,
I have 100% faith in my wife. I have 100% faith in God, but I
need him to prove his existence to me to believe. Okay? I listen,
I just need him to prove his existence. the second he proves
his existence, I'm a I'm a Christian. But I have 100% faith in
him. Okay, that's all I'm saying. That doesn't make any sense,
bro. >> 100% trust and faith. I think [clears throat] it's
your prerogative to do that, but >> Okay. Well, it's not
for her. It's for >> But anyway, Pearl's new boyfriend
has some very exciting and high energy content for us to watch.
>> Yeah, Far is tier list.
Far is still pretending to be a virgin as far as I know.
Uh, I kind of doubt that it's true, but as far as I know,
>> So, the next one, uh, someone mentioned it,
or I think someone mentioned it, uh,
is the sports bar, and that is B tier. Yeah, he may look confused
and sad and low energy, but just know that this guy with his
little Pikachu hat and little earring is going to teach you about
the 16 commandments of getting puned. >> She's like, >> Destiny
said he tapped that. So, yeah. Wait, did Destiny say that? Wait,
Gregor Samsa.
Ain't no way. No way. He would just leak details about somebody
for no reason. Doesn't sound like him. Said she wanted to date
him. Uh, that I believe that I fully believe. If you don't believe
that, you're probably high.
>> Think about how weird that was, by the way. Just think
about how weird that was. Far with while Destiny was married,
moved from LA into his apartment into like his apartment complex.
That is like
that's totally psychotic.
Okay.
That's like completely and utterly psychotic. know
that she she met him like two times and then moved into the same
apartment complex he lived in in Miami specifically like to be
around him to do content with him or something. No, that's not
normal. That's by the way I think that's like isn't it like $3,000
a month minimum to live there? Like it's like $300 or $5,000
a month to live in that place. That's crazy.
Okay, that was that was wild. I wouldn't complain. No, you say
you wouldn't complain.
I'm just telling you that that is ludicrous. Didn't Far live
with Cupot? No, she lived with I don't think she live with Cupot.
I thought she lived with Meera
somehow. Not totally sure. >> Like gushing like writing
poetry to him, right? He's like >> that whole arc was super
weird.
Yeah, she like moved there and then she was supposed to go and
do content with him and then she never did. I don't even know.
That person's like very weird to me. I don't know. I don't know
anything about that person. Not that I'm talking I'm not talking
I don't know. I don't know what she had going on that that seemed
like the best option was to move to Miami directly into like
Destiny's apartment complex. I don't know what she had going
on. Okay. I'm just saying it's like uh it would have to be crazy
to understand it. Okay. I'd have to
young person with mad cash. I guess so.
Like okay. That's the reason she likes him in the first place
probably is because he's he's dismissive. He's
>> I remember her being on stream with Destiny saying she
signed a lease on an apartment in his complex. Oh, that wasn't
how she No, she didn't let him know that way. I'm pretty sure
Destiny I'm pretty sure Destiny co-signed it, didn't he? Didn't
he co-sign her lease? I'm pretty sure.
I'm like 95% sure of that, actually.
I'm pretty sure he co-signed her lease
knowing knowing that she had like insane money. I think it was
just like she didn't have I don't know if she had credit or what
the deal would have been, but I think he I think he coached,
>> you know, distracted, whatever. Cool. Thanks for the
poetry. Awesome. >> That is exactly how it should look.
She should be chasing.
>> So, give this dusty princess his flowers and heels and
make sure that you listen to his advice if you want to score
someone that's top of the line like Pearl. Speaking of Red Pill
advice, you guys remember Grandma Tamasi, right? He's featured
>> Oh, hold on. Maybe Hold on. You're you're kind of right,
Latigious Gamer, that I don't know why I don't know why he would
need to cosign, but also I think it had something to do with
and I just trying to remember. It might have been that she wasn't
in Miami when she was like signing the lease. Maybe she wasn't
there. Maybe they just couldn't see that
like like you can give somebody a bank statement, but how do
they know that that bank statement is real, right?
Yeah. Yeah. So maybe if she didn't have an established credit
history and she just gives a bank statement, here's all the money
I make. They just go like, what the [__] How do I
even know that's
>> In a couple of videos on my channel where he was desperate
to get my nudes and got trolled multiple times. There are a couple
of things you need to know about Grandma Tamasi. Number one,
he is the self-proclaimed grandma of the red pill. And number
two, Pearl looked up to him and has parited a lot of his points.
Oh, and another thing you need to know is that he is a big fan
of Pearl. >> And I I was trying to get him to like mentor
me. Like and I was saying I would pay him for his time. I really
looked up to him. Like honestly, I thought like he was so smart
and like I just really loved his stream. He went on this like
podcast and then was like I forgot. I don't remember what he
said. >> Maybe then you'll go die in a fiery car wreck
somewhere.
Go
away.
You want the red pill to die? You're already quite well. Thank
you very much. >> It really hurt my feelings though to
be >> Pearl's boyfriend is out here retweeting this guy,
>> dude. Okay, hold on. The best part about that, you guys
know what caused the
Fun fact, the Pearl Rolo rift. You guys know what caused that,
right? Do you remember the content that caused that? Cuz I remember
cuz I remember everything. It was that Fentes stream. Fuentes
and Rolo were on a pearl stream together and Fuentes just kept
on him over and over and over again.
And
I think Brolo eventually just goes like, "This is Pearl. I don't
know why you invited me to this." And does does he leave?
Oh, I feel like I have to go find that now cuz I think that is
what what burned the bridge between those two.
Oh my god. The funny thing is is this might all work out for
Pearl if Fentes is just mogging everyone right now though. Well,
here's the thing. I think Fentes is pretty good about, oh, you
guys were ride or dies with me. I think he'll like give all of
those people another chance to like collab with him. Like, I
bet you he would collab with Zirka even with Zurka's allegations.
Uh, he definitely he still collabs with Sneo. He would still
collab with Sneo almost certainly. I think he'd collab with Pearl.
I'm I'm almost positive he would collab with Pearl again.
Ethan Ralph. Maybe not Ethan Ralph. Ethan Ralph's like betrayed
him a couple times though. See the weird Sam Pepper ship Asian
Andy stream on a perpetual loop while he crashes out on Twitter
and the sketchy Indian scammer is trying to say kid with sunglasses
lost an eye. No, I I did not see that. Not been following a lot
of kick stuff recently, Xormy. Sorry, buddy. I should get back
into the kick IRL stuff that there's some good there. I've also
heard that Darius streams have been pretty good. like Darius
has like Mercur and another like an Asian girl and he's a lot
of people having a lot of emotions over and over again. Might
have to check that out. I haven't looked into any of it, but
I've heard it's pretty good. So, possibly there's some content
there that we could check out later as well. >> And even
complimenting him in the title of his content, but I'm sure that's
just Pearl's boyfriend showing how alpha he is to not care what
his girlfriend thinks. In fact, Pearl's boyfriend showcases his
love for her in his content all of the time. Are all women secretly
feminists? With Pearl's face right next to a bunch of other women
subtitled, they are fooling you. The best part is that he puts
>> dude. Dude, Pearl is like so heavily photoshopped here.
What the Dude, it What filter did he pass this through? Like
an uncanny valley filter? I just make me feel uncomfortable with
all of these people. What is this? I don't even know who this
person is. puts her next to all of her favorite people, including
one woman who said Pearl probably has AIDS from [laughter] >> That's
Morgan Ariel. Okay. You suck black and probably have AIDS. Jesus.
>> Black guys. And another girl, Sarah Stalk, that humiliated
her on her own show, which resulted in her getting kicked off.
>> Sarah, what's going on? So, what's up with the gaslighting,
Sarah? What's up with the the calling me a >> Oh god.
How did I miss this?
This is like peak content. Pearl and Sarah Stock had like a fight.
I didn't see this. Was this during the egirl civil war a couple
months ago? Oh man, I can't believe I missed this. [__]
>> Or you know I didn't insult you. What was that about?
>> You did insult her. What? That's the gaslight. WAIT,
THAT'S THE GASLIGHT.
You started this. >> Oh, where's the man? You just showed
the the ring. You want clout. You want clicks. You want Shut
the [__] up. >> Yeah, you're saying I'm getting
run through by black guys.
>> Your last eight boyfriends were black guys. So, it's
not like
>> she she shows up. She joins all of the most racist circles
and then she's like, "I can't believe you guys point out that
all my boyfriends are black. I can't believe you guys are racist
like this. Why? Why can't you believe it? Seems like the most
natural, obvious thing in the world. Yes, you hang out with like
purely racist people, racist and misogynist people, and then
they notice that you only date plus-sized black guys.
I Yeah, that's the
how what did you think was going to happen? Where did you think
you were? What communities do you think you were a part of? >> You've
hid this fact. >> Is it true or is it not true? >> THAT'S
NOT THAT'S NOT TRUE.
OH, >> if you want to insinuate that current boyfriend
and your previous boyfriend, you're not married to either of
them, SO HOW IS THAT? >> OH, [laughter] YEAH. I Why is
Pearl denying? What is SHE DOING? >> MY [screaming] GOD.
>> Pearl's boyfriend really has a talent for video production,
and you can see it shine through here with how he mixes the audio.
You can't hear what Pearl is saying here, but maybe that's for
the
official thing. >> Her boyfriend has some interesting points
to make about her, like how he insinuates that she's a rand grifter.
>> All women are feminists, especially the ones that say
they are not. They never say they're anti-feminists when they're
in their party years, 18 to 28. It's always when they want to
settle down. >> In fact, he doubles down and insinuates
it again. Just like you must assume that all women are promiscuous,
you must understand that all women are feminists. >> Throwing
your girlfriend under the bus calling her.
>> Dude, what?
Do we just have to go watch this guy's content?
Hold on. Just He's playing like Fertise, right?
Fly. Fiss. Why did I say Deise? Fiss. He's paying playing
your release
with anime
animations going on while just monotone
reading something. That's not Moonlight. Wait, that's not Moonlight
Sonata. Moonlight Sonata is a different part of the same symphony,
isn't it? >> Especially the ones that say they are not.
They never say they're anti-feminists when they're in their party
years. >> No, that's not Moonlight Sonata, bro. What? Moonlight
Sonata is or is maybe it's one of the movements in Moonlight
There's like a better movement in Moonlight Sonata that's way
more complicated though. >> 18 to 28. It's always when
they want to settle down. >> In fact, he doubles down and
insinuates it again. >> Just like you must assume that
all women >> Yeah, it's the
releases Mozart. What? Dude, do I know anything? I don't know
anything about music. It's not Mozart. What the [__]
are you talking about? It's but it's different. It is Beethoven,
but it's different. I'm Dude, >> I'm on one today. Okay,
I I'm I'm losing it today. All right, bye now. >> Promiscuous.
You must understand that all women are feminists. >> Throwing
your girlfriend under the bus, calling her a feminist for clout
is just so red pill alpha of him. Honestly, judging by this video,
you would think that he hates her because it's just so strange
how it seems like he's just constantly dunking on her. >> Just
go under any social media post where women is selling purity.
It does not matter if she's a single mom or cleavage showing
brainless Tik Tocker pretending to do housewife dudes for clout.
And look how the men gawk and say that she is a real woman and
that we need to protect her at all costs. Pathetic when they
say we're dude
it like honestly if the Wait, what?
Wait, why did I I didn't mean to pause on Impath Jam like that.
Okay, my bad. That wasn't what I was going for. But I I almost
feel like this guy's doing parody. Maybe this guy's like a genius
and he's parodying Red Pill cuz I there's no way he thinks this
is good. He's got classical music with anime on and he's just
like all women are
even when they say they're not
feminists. All women are feminists.
Bro, what? There's no way he sincerely thinks that's good content
that he could be a content creator. I I will say
if there's like if there's one thing I can see already,
it's that him and Pearl are the exact same caliber of content
creator, which is wild. Like neither one's batting out of their
league. They are they are both three out of 10 content creators.
Maybe two out of 10. Okay, it's not good. >> Infer that
they are right-wing and racist. They're trying to signal to naive
men that they have made good choices with their vagina and that
they have standards. women [__] black men, Latino
men, etc. WOULD MAKE >> OH, RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT,
RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT. I forgot this guy's
So, a lot of Dominican people say that they're not black. People
from the Dominican Republic, they say they're not black.
Uh, that's that'll be why she says, "I forgot in the egirl civil
war she actually brought this up. She said this verbatim." Um,
actually, uh, I'm not dating a black guy right now. I'm dating
a Dominican. [laughter] >> make her seem less viable to
the hot Listen,
that might be valid,
>> but it's not valid with this guy. I'm sorry. Like, >> I'm
sorry. This guy is literally black. I'm I like I I don't know
what to tell you. That that guy's black. He's not Latino even.
That guy is black and >> etc. would make her seem less
viable to the hot area she wants. So, her being racist is her
selling a full purity. Very sneaky. I know. he's calling out
his own girlfriend for selling the lie of purity. Pearl's boyfriend
fails to explain to his audience of 150 viewers is that this
also applies to men. He promotes being this alpha guy who knows
game and then he settles for the type of girl that he spends
his entire video criticizing. He is in his own way selling purity,
but apparently it's only grifting when it's his competition doing
it. He's in competition with women to siphon money from simps.
Pearl's boyfriend once again shows up for Pearl by sliding into
my replies, complimenting me about how I'm so attractive that
I can get a husband today if I wanted to. It makes me wonder
why aren't him and Pearl married? Doesn't he believe that she's
pretty enough to be married today, too? Meanwhile, as Pearl's
boyfriend is in my replies, showering me in compliments for all
of his followers to see. Pearl has me blocked. She's trying so
hard to obscure me from her followers so that they dare not see
the polite and nice things I have to say about her. >> Bro,
this is >> And right after his reply to me, he opens up
a Twitter space talking about how he loves women who say the
something that I'm known for. >> There is no nice enough
on earth where if I found out the G
>> Wait, it that's not what Britney Britney Venti is not
known for saying yet, is
What do you mean she's what? Why is she saying she's known for
that? >> Girl uses the n word that I I that'd be enough
for me to be attracted to her. >> He's just publicly announcing
how he >> Can you be black and be known for saying the
I I don't think that's a thing. If you're if you're black, you
can't be known for saying the word. It doesn't make a difference
if you say the What do you mean you're known for that? >> The
[__] you talking about? >> Someone like me
more attractive than Pearl. But don't worry, Pearl. I'm sure
he's just doing one of his manipulative tactics where he's colder
to his girlfriend than other girls that he's trying to get with.
I guess that's also why he's promoting all over his Pearl the
Parrot repeats his tweets falsely claiming that it saves marriages
and she actually ends up getting community noted with sources
proving otherwise. If it did save marriages and is actually a
good thing, then tell me why her boyfriend tried to quit. Here
he is claiming it's so easy to quit after 2 weeks and yet he
failed to quit himself. So now he has to broadcast to his audience
that actually addiction isn't real and that they should totally
be
bro. Why would you share why are you sharing this about yourself
at all? The
Sam Jackson. No, I don't think Sam Jackson's known for saying
the N word.
He is Sam Samuel L. Jackson is not known for saying the N word.
He's known for being that. Okay.
He's that guy. But imagine I said I I can't quite say it. Okay.
But that's what he's known for. >> Oh yeah. Also, he's
known for saying Yeah, exactly. >> Like he is. He says,
"Why do you think that women hate that men watch so much? It's
how they can tell their wife sucks in bed." Clearly, he is announcing
that Pearl Rock.
>> DUDE, STOP CONNECTING DOTS, BRITNEY. world with him
interacting with all these OAF girls on X, saying how he'll take
money from them and insinuate
to see. He's in this space with his mouth watering about his
ex's juicy booties. You know, when Pearl has none. >> Listen,
like, man, have you have you cracked a girl with a fat ass lately?
I'm sure you have. >> What the
What the [__] She's right there. I wouldn't call
it like fat, you know. Not lately.
>> Yeah. Well, I'm sure that it's never as nice in real
life as it is
>> in the pictures. Like I go to the gym every day. I see
women like this. These are like second tier, third tier women
in the gym I go to. >> Pearl, do you have any more we could
>> How about you guys tell me the greatest asses of all
time? Like if you you know there's like a >> Do you have
any like nominations for the greatest ass of all time? I do,
but they're women of my past, and I don't think you would be
uh you [laughter] want to see that. >> Same here. >> She
just sits there in the corner listening to this. You just know
that he is pulling his peeper to all of the women that Pearl
sees about on a daily basis. Seems like a healthy relationship.
I think this all plays into why Pearl promotes to her audience,
too. What up, guys? I'm Pick Me Pearl,
and I'm not like those other girls. I just let my boyfriend walk
all over me for clout cuz I'm mid. >> I've always been
a certified mid. >> She'll complain that women want to
be hosed so bad. Even Christian women will defend being naked
at all costs. You never see the Trout Eye Girls without a pound
of makeup, short skirts, dresses, and using God for money. Yet,
they insult and gaslight you if you notice. Yeah, they do. Pearl
even shows more skin than the girls that she criticizes to her
male audience. It's different when she prom. >> Bro, here's
a real here's here's the real question. Why would you wear skirts
when you got knees like this? What is this? There's like eight
different kneecaps going on in this one knee. Absolute zero out
of 10 knees. Gross. Get that [__] off my timeline.
>> Then then the girls that to her male >> Oh [__]
it's a it's a tree tweet.
It's a tree of logic tweet. Nice >> audience. It's different
when she promotes what she considers
Hold on. Yeah. Yeah, I know. Cyba, I'm doing the elbows too pointy
thing for somebody who's already like pretty objectively not
attractive. So, I think it's funny. It's a little commentary.
All right. >> Right. She's retweeting women, wagging her
finger at them for being quote, but never mind her signal boosting
said women and constantly making her male following look at them.
She even runs a bunch of these polls where she's like, "Hey guys,
look at her. Are they fake?" But no, she's just asking the important
questions. Okay, the Red Pill Manosphere just loves doing this
thing where they use to profit, but it's only okay when they
do it. Speaking of profiting off of women, it's got me thinking,
why is Pearl's boyfriend with her? I think it's for him to be
provided for so that he can secure his financial future with
Pearl. He's made a ton of posts about
>> Remember Desty saying that most guys would be bending
over backwards to get with a girl who looked like Pearl when
they were closer. I
>> I thought Pearl was like kind of okay looking at one
point personally,
but uh unfortunately time has just gone on to show me I was totally
wrong on that. I didn't think she was like completely unattractive,
but she's kind of super
>> Giving money from women. He says, "If she has a side
dude that spoils her, then that's less money I got to spend on
her." Really showcasing his romantic side here. Why do I have
to pay if I can get everything I need from a woman for free?
He's literally bragging about how Pearl is getting nothing out
of this. Nothing will save you more money than being attractive.
And somehow Pearl >> Wait, that's just a truism. >> Was
desperate enough to take a man with neither. And how he just
>> dude, no way she chugjacked
a black guy. >> And somehow Pearl was desperate enough
to take a man with neither.
>> I don't even know if it works, but it just works cuz
she did it. Okay. Cuz she dared to she dared to try and she made
it work. All right. I don't think it's actually real, but she
dared to attempt it. And that I got to give her props for that.
Okay, you are you are the judge >> And how he just relishes
in taking money off of women. And it's really interesting because
Pearl has commented a lot about how women should just get over
a man stepping out on them because he's providing for them. But
apparently her boyfriend can just do that for free. I guess Pearl's
ad about how if a guy married her, he would get daddy's land
worked after all. It's one thing if a woman in a relationship
makes more money than the guy. I would say
>> I mean
listen
that guy maybe if that guy's like from not welloff parents I
could see him doing it. Okay. You think you think only women
only female gold diggers exist? This has to as a correlary it
has to exist for men. Okay.
If if the roles were reversed if it was like a a dude with a
bunch of money from his parents dating a way hotter woman. We
wouldn't even ask a question. We' just be like, "Oh yeah, I see.
Yeah, I see what's going on. >> Say that income disparities
are pretty common now. >> Dominicans in particular known
for this. Are Dominicans just like hot enough? They're just like
I'm trying to think of who is it. Colombian women or something?
Dominican guys are just they're just going to show up. Dominican
guys, they're just going to show up. They can dance. They're
hot. They're just like, "Yeah, I'll find an old lady with some
money. The solid 401k days." >> But that's not what this
is. And I think Pearl and her boyfriend seem to have a different
kind of arrangement, if you know what I mean.
>> Oh, it's Idubbbz. Wait, what the is What the is this
picture? What What is this picture? It's from this Halloween.
>> He's openly selling his product to men and trying to
get clout using Pearl's image. And he's like, "Yeah, my girlfriend
better buy me them video games while I tug my donger to them
women she be hating on all day." If you want women to do something,
tell them that they can't do it and they'll try to do it. >> The
hot women in the chat, please don't send me nudes. >> I
hate when women buy me video games. I hate it. >> It's
this weird humiliating sugar baby dynamic as opposed to a loving,
respectful relationship. The good news
>> Dobby the trans. I don't know. He was holding a trans
flag. That's what I meant is like a trans flag. I get that who
the people are.
Although I don't know why it would be Dobby and Snape. That doesn't
make any sense. Pearl just might be able to treat her baby to
some video games that he needs, and she can do it with the $500
that she charges her fans to have a call with her on her website.
Or maybe $500 simply isn't enough for Nino Cowo. So, Mommy Pearl
also sells a passive income course that resembles Andrew Tate's
Hustlers University. Because Pearl should be giving advice on
how to make a passive income when her YouTube wasn't even breaking
even right now. Now, I want you guys to guess how much you think
that she's charging. How much do you think Pearl's time is worth
for these courses? Pause the video and leave a comment below
with your guess. You can get rich
>> Uh, I don't know, dude. These these courses are meant
to they're like scam courses. You're meant to sell like four
copies of the course and everything else is just window dressing,
right? Like you're just scamming people whenever you're doing
this. for the low price of $3,000.
A steal for scholars. Asking chat GPT if you put your balls in
the condom are the exact magic.
>> Hey, it's Pearl. I know you're probably >> Words
I need to hear to immediately reach in my wallet and pay for
this course across multiple credit cards. Thank god that Pearl's
team clarifies that you can actually go into debt for the course.
Pearl and her team genuinely
team clarifies that you can
>> How much does it cost? $2,980.
You can split it across multiple cards or do a pay plan. Hence
the 1K minimum mentioned on the in the Facebook ad.
Dude, what
I man I had some super blackpilling thoughts the other day. It's
like as as economic situations worsen, okay, I feel like more
and more people will get to scamming and more and more people
will become as things get worse, you'd expect like people to
be more discerning with their money, but they'll actually get
more and more desperate and pay for more and more, right?
Like I feel like the only people making money right now, some
of the only people making money online are people who are just
openly scamming, like crypto scams, bunch of like this. And a
lot of other people look at and go, "That's really bad. You shouldn't
do that.
But but then I feel like eventually as things get worse, people
go, "Oh, need money. Like maybe I could do a crypto scam. Maybe
I can do some kind of scam." It's it's rough, dude. >> Actually
go into debt for the course. Pearl and her team.
>> True. Look at how gambling is taking off. Yeah. Well,
guess what? Gambling might be taking off on this stream soon.
Okay.
We have We've not done a stake sponsor yet. Possibly
to pay the bills. You may think that their audience are such
successful geniuses that they would just pay for anything. Don't
call it a scam just yet because you're also promised lifetime
access to all of Pearl's content. Like her course on quote the
art of making people feel comfortable. Yeah, that's what [laughter]
she's known for. Being pleasant would say is women challenging
men's authority. And I would argue that you are the same as a
blue-haired feminist.
Anyways, I will unmute you, but I do want to I do want to show
that you are also interrupting me. So, >> yeah, Pearl,
muting your guests is a very uh disrespectful thing to >> Okay,
I'm going to do it again.
Um, muting is just super disrespectful. You're muted. That was
rude. That was rude for you to point out that muting you was
rude. That was rude. Never do it >> Keep muting me. So
I if she's just going to keep muting me, there's I don't know
there's a point of being able to have a >> Problem is here's
the the challenge to >> you hear me? Am I muted or not?
>> You get to go on these you go on these shows and you
do over >> Can you hear me? >> I don't even know
when you're muting me or not. I'm not going to be able to have
a conversation with you. I don't think you're acting in good
faith right now. I'm going to have to end the stream with you
if you're going to continue.
>> Bro, I can't believe we missed out on all the Pearl
Davis Lulcow content for the past like 6 months or nine months,
however long Britney Venty's needed to collect all this stuff.
There's actually she's like a gold mine of content,
but like not in a good way. Obviously,
we we've missed out on all of it. Thank god for Britney Venty.
>> You need to mute me.
>> She's She's like the only Oh, wait. No, no way. She
does it again. She doesn't do it again. >> I don't even
know when you're muting me or not. I'm not going to be able to
have a conversation with you. I don't think you're acting in
good faith right now. I'm going to have to end the stream with
you if you're going to continue to mute
>> Yeah, you can't stop me. Look, it's either submit to
the rules of the show or don't. >> I think we're going
to have to close out then because [clears throat] you need to
let your audience decide who's over talking who. >> All right,
see you.
>> Other women that are more attractive and skilled would
be called delusional to think that their time is worth that much,
but Pearl's time and repackaged YouTube slop are definitely worth
$3,000
because she's really good at making people comfortable or something.
Can her staff photoshop her hair off of her dress displayed on
her website so that I feel more comfortable? And maybe some professional
makeup as well. Her website has this corny slogan that I absolutely
love. Dive into the ultimate media hub where freedom of speech
and expression isn't just a right, it's a vibe. Yeah, her copy
striking her coworker was definitely a vibe. >> It's not
until we stopped working together and I done my video that she
wanted to strike the video. >> Just free speech things.
Her website features six different segments of herself full of
old filler content that she just repackages to sell back to her
audience again. Apparently, Pearl's paywall website doesn't even
work according to her fans. They're just haters. And if you need
a testimony on Pearl charging $3,000 for her advice, her boyfriend
has been making videos since they've been dating and he has a
whopping 2,000 subs on YouTube. I would say Pearl is returning
to her roots on her money. >> Dude, I listen. That's what
Pearl needs to do, okay? She needs to start turning her boyfriend's
channel around because if he somehow becomes a famous YouTuber,
I will shell out the money, okay? I'll shell it out. I'll pay
for the course. Pearl is a genius. If she can make that guy popular,
she is actually a genius. She deserves the money. eyncing projects
and taking in homeless guys. You know, buying them video games
with the money she siphons from her simps. But apparently, according
to Pearl, he's not black. He's Dominican. >> Hey, I know
black. I ain't no black. >> I know black. Impossibly. I
ain't no black. I ain't Dominican. Be looking just like me. Be
like be having the same hair. I be touching you like no.
No. They try to sal that up. I'm like, "No, you black." >> Sorry.
The idea of like the only thing I know the Dominican Well, I
know the Dominican Republic for a couple things, but the thing
I know about before like as a reputation thing is the dancing,
right? Like they they all dance. He tries to salsa that [__]
up. He does little hand gestures. >> And Dominican be looking
just like me. Be like be having the same hair. I be touching
you like it not the same. It not the same. It not the same. They
try to salsa that off. I'm like, "NO, YOU BLACK." NO, NO, NO.
I AIN'T NO BLACK DOMINICA. HERE, Pearl is salsaing away her boyfriend's
African future as if she >> dated she is. I was I was saying
before I knew Cherry that that was what I knew Dominicans for
is uh dancing. >> Plenty of black guys in the past. I think
that she's distancing herself from black men as a business decision
to cater to her audience. >> A girl, even if she got pregnant
with an Albanian outside of marriage, it would be like, "Yeah,
you're not that's one of ours. Like, you don't and nobody's really
going to encourage But if she got pregnant, let's say, with a
Dominican's baby. Laughing a little too hard there. >> Wait,
wait, wait. >> With a Dominican's baby. >> Oh, that
is on Pearl's show. Oh, that is
That is
rough. [laughter] Was she dating the guy at the time? I Britney
needs to elaborate on the timeline there. Was she dating the
Dominican guy when this woman said this to her face?
>> Laughing a little too hard there, Pearl. She's out here
making multiple videos talking about her black fatigue. Meanwhile,
her entire dating history is black guys. >> I I've dated
mostly black guys. >> And it's interesting that that's
her type because in her London studio, she hired all of these
black guys to be around her all of the time [laughter] on her
daddy's dime. So, I wonder what's going on there.
>> Dude, I told you it was the perfect segue from earlier.
Okay, from the Emmy video to this. The absolute perfect segue.
She hates her parents.
I'm a black guys. That's That's exactly what every white girl,
every rich white girl says. She That's how she gets back at her
parents for like controlling her, for making her do she didn't
want to do. Okay,
I'm telling you, it's just like a known pattern. And again, I'm
just observing the pattern. I'm not saying this is bad. It's
fine. I'm just observing the pattern. Okay, they're using these
black dudes, okay? Just as a as a weapon.
You hate to see. >> Hey, have you ever discussed with your
parents that that certain attraction that you have? >> Oh,
[laughter]
>> yeah. They know. They don't care. >> I think that
the reason that Pearl goes for black eyes is >> Have you
ever you ever discussed Have you ever discussed with your with
your parents your total
your total need to suck black Pearl? Have you ever discussed
that with your parents? Pearl
>> because she thinks that it's all that she can get. She
has repeatedly broadcasted the sentiment that black men have
a stereotype of liking unattractive white women. So, I think
she really took that belief in and she feels like she has to
provide for black guys who clearly love and respect her so much,
you know, enough to publicly humiliate her because it's her only
option. I do
>> dude, if Pearl had any humor to her, she would recreate
that shot in her London studio. Okay, she got a big couch in
her London studio. She would sit in the center of it and she
would pay all those guys to stand around. Now, you might have
to do some Lord of the Rings style force perspective to make
her look like a small woman instead of a like instead of like
Sasquatch, but you could do it. You could force some perspective
there and make her look very small compared to black guys. It
would make sense. >> I think that she likes white guys,
but she just feels like it's out of her reach. So, she goes for
what she views as realistic. >> I like both. I like black
and white guys. Yeah. >> What was your experience dating
between the two? date [snorts] between white and
>> I've only dated black guys. [laughter] >> She's
out here publicizing about how she's losing all of this weight
and reposting her totally not black boyfriends post saying how
women need to get skinny in order.
>> Dude,
when you're tired of dating black and Dominican men and want
to date white men, [laughter]
dude, they're both self-hating. They're like a They're like a
dual self-hating couple. He's like, "I'm Dominican, so I only
date white fat women because they're the only ones who would
accept me." And Pearl is sitting there like, "Uh, I would love
to date white guys, but I have to date black dudes and Dominicans
cuz you know, they're the only ones who will date ugly fat white
>> To get white guys." Pearl's been a heavier woman all
these years, so I think that contributes to her feeling that
white guys are out of her reach. >> I always knew from
a young age I was kind of mid, not not necessarily beautiful,
and I don't mean this to insult me, but you know, I would look
at women more attractive than me. Uh, OoFy Slaughter Ofy Killer,
thank you for the new subscription. Appreciate that. >> We
get more opportunities. I was also kind of fat. >> Number
four is if you always find that you are waiting for your friend
to get done being raised on. >> I think you're gorgeous.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> You can see the pain in her face
when he's talking about this. You know, this definitely happened
to her. So, it begs the question, why doesn't Pearl just break
up with her boyfriend? Well, it's not going to be pretty if she
does because Pearl is trapped by >> uh Pearl isn't even
super ugly. She just has dog water self-esteem and it's a gross
personality. No, no, she's actually also kind of ugly.
Like like I don't know what it is. It maybe it's like something
she just never thought she was attractive so she never learned
how to like hold her face correctly. But her face is like super
asymmetrical. Like I unironically her face is super asymmetrical.
Um, it's not I don't know how to des She's like weird looking
and she also is like aging really fast.
No, no, no. She's not just normal. She's not just normal looking.
She's not like she she can't use I I'm telling you, she tries
to use makeup to make herself look hotter, right? But she can't
even do that. Like, at least a lot of women can use makeup to
make themselves look more attractive. She's like totally failing
at that. Okay, but throw stones in a glass house. I don't know
what you're saying there, but good luck.
I I'm going to just tell you how it is, buddy. You can you can
say whatever you like. I'm sorry. You're kind of coping though
if you think she's like just look at any of the pictures in here
that Pearl posted herself.
Britney has Britney did jump scares for the first like 10 minutes
of just photos Pearl Posted trying to say she's attractive. Trying
to say, "Oh, I'm looking good today." That's how it is, man.
Hey, was watching on X, but had to log in here to tell you the
that the LOTR trick photography to make Pearl not look like Sasquatch
is the funniest thing I've ever heard anyone say. Thanks, man.
Well, you're welcome, Viz. Why are you watching on Twitter?
What's the deal with that? But thank you. Appreciate it. >> By
her audience, they're going to tell her she's going to die alone
as thanks for her catering to them. Or perhaps they'll say >> I
don't know if you guys
if it matters to you. I'm not ugly.
If it ma if it matters. I don't think it should matter. If it
matters to you though,
um I went out. Oh, no. Never mind. >> Say you'd be married
if you wanted to be. So now she's stuck having to market her
videos, humbling herself as a certified mid. Maybe if she actually
believed in redemption, she would be able to leave this cult
that she's a part of. Despite her Christian upbringing, she often
speaks badly about the church and gives women zero grace, repeatedly
condemning them even if they try to return to their faith and
make their life right. Just
>> This is something that actually me off about Andrew
as well and like a lot of the red pill people. Dude, why are
you over there like preaching Christianity, preaching forgiveness,
preaching you can make anything good if you find God. And then
when people find God, you go, you're a fake [__]
What?
Like you you have no charity for people. You just have you have
like nothing.
I It's It's so up that that people are like, "Oh yeah, come join
Christianity. You can you can come back from anything. You could
it doesn't matter. Like you're fine." And then they like go and
they try to become Christian. They're like, "Ah, this this person's
still a whore." Okay,
that's [__] up, dude. What the >> Things has
made her comfy red bed and now she has to lie in it
>> because a lot of those these are fake Christians. No,
a lot of the men are fake Christians.
Anybody who uses Christianity as a cudgle to attack somebody
with is like a fake Christian basically. Like I'm sorry if you're
going on the internet and you're like going to go and talk to
make a bunch of women like hate themselves and use Christianity
and like your Christian values as the pretext for it, you're
a fake Christian. That's not That's not a part of Christianity,
bro. What are you doing? Most Christians are fake Christians,
I suppose. I suppose >> until the next black guy comes
along because her boyfriend, >> sorry, I'm cut I'm cutting
Britney off when she's when she's landing. Uh, >> they
try to return to their faith and make their life right. Just
pick me things has made her comfy red bed and now she has to
lie in it until the next black guy comes along because her boyfriend
is already tweeting about how all women are replaceable. Pearl
does have one other option actually. She can see if JF gets
[laughter]
I am here by I can't do the voice.
I am here I can't do the voice. I I literally was about to do
an Indian accent. I literally the first syllable was Indian and
I just gave up immediately. Okay. I am hereby off [laughter]
I did an Indian again. I'm not trying it. I'm sorry. I tried
twice. Both both run-ups were Indian and instantly and I'm like
trying to do French. I can't help it. I I need to stop. I need
to >> Is still on the table to be a trad wife in Quebec.
For those of you that aren't aware, his mentally disabled baby
mama/girlfriend or whatever that he dropped off in the woods
is still missing to this day. So, he's looking to replace her
quick. The world definitely needs another hypocrite siphoning
money from their simps and stoking the flames of the gender.
>> Well, hold on. Canadian caller. This is the one thing
you could possibly argue for dating Pearl on the basis of. Okay,
if you're like an athlete, there is an NFLer out there who could
create like the next Kelsey genetic dynasty. Okay. Yes. Pearl
is like she's got the craziest genes. Okay,
take one for the team. Shemag Imagine that that skeletal structure.
All right. in all of your imagine having daughters. Pearl, I
don't know. I don't know what happened in Pearl's youth that
she didn't go up for sports like as much as she should have.
She played college volleyball, right? She looks so unathletic,
but realistically, you would create like basketball stars, volleyball
stars,
right? Those genetics are crazy.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You could make a boxer, you could make like
a like whatever field of physical endeavor they want to go into,
they could be some of the best. Okay. Pearl. Pearl has that's
why she only dates black guys. Actually,
that's her mind. Okay, she's out here getting ready to make the
next Patrick Mahomes. Okay, that's her goal. She only dates black
guys cuz Patrick Mahomes is coming out next. Okay, that's the
goal. That's That's where we're going. That's what we're doing.
>> War. This video was quite the project. So, show it some
love. If I made you comfortable, you can go ahead and support
my content in the links below. Do you guys think that they take
turns sitting in the chair or do they sit in it together? Leave
a comment below. My professional advice to Pearl that I'm going
to charge $3,000 for is that she should just never log off. And
please keep continuing doing literally anything possible.
[laughter]
>> Sorry. Miracle terrorist Marvin. Damn. Pearl has the
body techone wishes to get a husband because you'll need to.
Thanks for watching. I'll see you guys later.
Brutal.
Okay, that was crazy. Wow, that was good stuff.